the 911 peace be with you
we have another incredible story so many
people are coming to this beautiful way
of life this way of life that provides
peace happiness purpose you know what
your purpose in life is when you live in
this way of light because it provides
all the rational logical evidences the
proofs it's not something this you jump
into our blind belief and faith it
provides everything you need to test it
to make sure that it is indeed not
man-made but from the Creator and our
next guest he tested it he verified it
and he said you know what there's no
other way except this way and he used to
be a Christian went to the nation and he
came to the way of life of all the
messengers of God Islam that complete
and total submission only to the crater
not worshipping anyone else but the one
who created creation that's Islam we'll
be right back with his story here on the
D show
this is the thesis the danger
this is the thing is 15 this is the
thing
Salam alaikum alaikum sit down - let me
look at peace be with you Sheikh how are
you mom did he laugh I'm very happy to
have you on the show I actually
interviewed your brother right Iman
Kassam Khan yes yes and people can go to
the Dean show to watch that it was a
show we did did Snoop Doggy Dogg come to
real Islam and you got to watch that
show to see to hear the answer so that's
at the Dean show.com website Mountain
costume calm you're his younger brother
yes yeah so how are you how's merciful
yeah
now let's start off look you said some
Arabic words we said assalamu alaikum I
defined that it means peace be with you
are the main people that we want to
reach out to is the not yet Muslims the
are our brothers in humanity because you
know we want to share this beautiful
message with the world because we care
about people don't ya so you mentioned
Allah just before we start off with this
what does allowed me the love means the
God Allah is the one that created the
one who creates everything the one who
is in control of everything and the one
whom everything returns to you know the
one whom is the decider of all of the
affairs of all of the people who he
created on this earth you know he's the
supreme being the one that some people
call God some people say Lord but we
until all of those attributes by saying
Allah is Jesus God no Jesus is not God
who was Jesus Jesus was one of the
prophets of Allah subhana WA Ta'ala is
what's his name
ferrara Hamid is he god no people say
that he's God incarnate yeah they made a
mistake he's not he's not God he is not
the Creator he's not the Supreme Being
you know at all it's a loss upon what
Allah the one who created everything
including those ones whom they attribute
to saying that is he's God don't Jews
and Christians for our Arabic speaking
they also used the word Allah correct
yeah they do
now you investigated that you didn't
just jump into it's not you were from a
Christian background is that right right
tell us a little bit about your story
well
the story was that I first came into the
Nation of Islam at one point and lost
hundred Allah blessed me to start
practicing Islam based on the Quran and
the Sunnah and that's a short story you
know hopefully by the grace of Allah so
Allah that Allah forgives me for all of
the misgivings that I had prior to the
information that he blessed me with and
now we utilized the information that
Allah support that I blessed us with in
order to try to help to be pleasing to
Allah support that I live the type of
life that Allah created us to live so
Allah but before the nation you're just
like your brother where you are a
Christian right we're a Christian came
up in a Christian household Baptists
Methodists Jehovah Witness well you were
Jehovah Jehovah Witnesses which one was
for you first
after sergeyeva Baptists okay well
Baptists going to the church with my
grandfather but my mother you know what
my father you know he didn't go that
often but you know and then you know
hamdulillah a lost fun without I blessed
us too to accept what we thought was
Islam anyway was back in the Nation of
Islam and then a lot of Spadina blessed
us to progress and to start practicing
based on the Quran and the Sunnah of the
Prophet peace be upon him so you went
from the Baptist Christian what had you
leaved the Baptist Christian
denomination to go to the Jehovah
Witness just the my mother yeah you know
she was the one in charge so we went
where my mother wanted us to go so you
weren't really were you reflecting were
you just like okay I'm just following my
parents all we were there you were there
we were there but at one point because
we have to assume it means make a
conscious decision is this the truth or
is it nice based on evidence or is this
just something that I'm following along
blending in on Sundays you know were you
singing in the choir no no as a matter
of fact I did yeah you know but you know
at some point you know as you grow a
little bit older you get to the point
where you start making your own
decisions some point you know you go
based on what your parents say and what
they direct you to and then when
as you get a little bit older and you
start utilizing the faculties that are
lost upon or thought I bless you with
you start making decisions for yourself
and you know by traveling and moving
around you know and hearing and being
able to read a little bit and witnessing
things then I became familiar with a few
Muslims that gave me a little
information and my father was getting
their information at the same time and
he kind of pulled the trigger in the
beginning and became Muslim
you know back at the nation time and
then he came in and asked me about it
and I visited and I accepted and then
over a period of time over a period a
few years then both of us started doing
more study and we decided that what was
best for us was to practice the Deen of
practice Islam based on what allah
subhanaw taala said in quran and the
sunnah of the prophet peace be upon him
now what about Jesus being Lord Savior
dying for your sins well you know that's
that's another whole you know whole show
but you know I didn't ever believe that
in the beginning but again it was
something that you know was given to us
you know as far as the parents you know
this is what we study this is what we
follow this is what we look to and
because we didn't have any choice at
that particular time but now so but but
have you had these talks with other
Christians now that you you ended up
leaving the religion of your parents or
actually your father accepted Islam but
you left what you were upon as a child
really not really thinking too much did
you think a lot of it like okay
this is supposed to be salvation for me
if I don't believe that Jesus died for
my sins a person will tell you're going
to the Hellfire believe it or not I
didn't think about it like yeah you know
for myself I didn't think about it like
that once I started thinking for myself
and and investigating for myself I made
a conscious decision to to study more
about Islam proper you know based on the
Quran and the Sunnah and hamdulillah has
been good for me you know because since
then and after accepting Islam proper
douwe you know in the institutions you
know Department of Corrections back in
Georgia Pennsylvania Virginia and so
forth and you know with the help of
allah subhanaw taala did at least no
less than between 800 and about 1200
Shahada so these are questions that you
get asked a lot so someone says look my
parents they taught me that Jesus died
for my sins that he's God he's one in
three in a Trinity how do you tackle
this question well you know pretty much
I mean we you know we do just the
minimum yeah on that you know because
you know I think about a story you know
briefly that one day Omar Amina khattab
radhi'allahu anhu was given some of the
info he was reading some information to
rasoolallah some of my Hollywood Salaam
and he was telling me it was some of the
Christian doctrine and then rasulullah
salallahu long got upset and he told him
he said isn't it enough that i gave you
or that i gave you the information that
i lost the part that i bless me with why
would you spend time with that you know
what i mean so you know we don't spend a
lot of time with it the way that i do to
Dawa we don't spend a lot of time with
it and you know we just thank Allah
support a lot that he blessed us to have
you know strong Eman enough you know
until we feel comfortable that we don't
have to rely to go back on those
particular things and those particular
questions and a lot of the informations
that we had studied and we live before
you know we just give it as needed you
know so we don't do back we don't study
the Bible and go into it and then recite
different passages from the Bible and so
forth because the Quran itself you know
it's enough what is better than the word
of allah subhanaw taala
given based on what he said or what he
gave far as the revelation you know to
all of the people his companions and the
people that came after him all the way
down to us today we're gonna take a
break and so we're gonna continue on
healing here on the Deen show and go
anywhere
I am Not Afraid to stand alone if Allah
is by my side I am not afraid to stand
alone I am not afraid to stand alone if
Allah is by my side
I am Not Afraid to stand alone I am Not
Afraid to stand alone if a box by my
side I am Not Afraid
you
back here on the Dean show
sheikh Tariq yes and we talked about
your story people get a little bit
familiar with you we talked about you
given or helping people come to this way
of life the way of life that brings
peace contentment happiness is the
fastest growing way of life Islam
submission to only the Creator and you
didn't want to worship the creation we
love Jesus is there something now that
you know when you're doing the Dawa that
what do you tell people your
relationship with Jesus is now well I
mean I respect him as one of the
prophets of allah subhanaw taala you
know just like I I'm excited about the
fact that that I worship the Creator the
one who gave each one of them the
revelation or revelation but I don't
look to him as the one that I follow I
look to the last the last prophet peace
be upon him Prophet Muhammad SAW Allah
Allah's Salam I look to him and you know
we always find out you know if somebody
always tells us follow the last
instruction you know if you have a job
you have people working for you you know
if somebody comes and gives you some
information you know and then you come
over there and tell them something and
then they said well somebody else told
me this and you always tell them follow
the last instruction yeah so the last
prophet peace be upon the Prophet
Muhammad Salaam
you know is the one that we need to
follow so we just made that transition
in order to do the things that's going
to bring us closer to allah subhana wa
ta'ala nation comes into the picture now
you went from baptist to jehovah and now
you jump into the nation of islam
how did why did you end up believing the
nation and coming to this way of life
now the true islam well because it was
true because it was true because it was
true there was no information that you
know needed to be dealt with you know
other than the fact that when i lost the
part that a lot touches your heart and
gives you the desire and the motivation
you know to follow correct Islam Quran
and the Sunnah there's nothing else for
you to stay you know and witness you
know because whenever I lost photo and
Allah gives you something that is good
then you always accept it
peace be upon him said that when Allah
wants to do something good for a person
he merely blesses them with the
understanding of the Deen understanding
of Islam and when I lost upon what Allah
put it in my heart to accept it and then
try to live it and practice it
at the same time din hamdulillah you
know there was no reason for me to stay
in the in the nation you know there was
no interest of mine to be you know to
stay back and try to you know fluctuate
and go back and form it just came into
it wholeheartedly and it was a blessing
from allah subhana wa ta'ala and it's
still a blessing right now it's like
when you know the pure monotheism what
this way of life from the Creator
teaches and only worshipping the creator
now you went from again christianity
worshipping the creation jesus who we
love revere is one of the mightiest
messengers of god we love him but as he
should be loved as a messenger not God
and then master fraud Muhammad in the
nation again being a lot of them making
him into a man to not worshipping
anything creation but only worshipping
the crater was that something now when
you explain to people that just makes
good all common sense doesn't it yeah I
mean it does but you know to be honest
with you Sheikh I really don't get
involved in that yeah at all because you
know my focus has been trying to
strengthen the families families yeah
you know the main reason why you know I
wake up in the morning for the sake of
allah subhanho wa taala you know is to
try to strengthen the ummah
you know in the only way that you could
strengthen the ummah is if you
strengthen the families you know because
the Ummah itself makes up families your
family my family you know his family
their family you know whenever you have
strong families with good understanding
of what is pleasing to allah subhanaw
taala and they work towards that
then all myself is gonna be strong but
if everybody is not strong in their
family and have a lot of issues and they
have a lot of misconceptions about this
deen about life in general what a loss
of north allah has created for them and
the system of life you know then we're
gonna have issues yeah so but whenever
we educate ourselves you know because
that's the two major problems that we
have as far as trying to educate the
rest of the community and strengthen
them on my to major part problems that
we have is number one that
lack of information and education of
Islam and what allah subhanho wa taala
has created for us and also people don't
feel lots of hundred amma you know what
i mean they do anything because they
don't have that desire to please allah
they really don't believe in allah
support allah the way that they say that
they believe because if they knew what
allah subhanho wa taala had obligated us
you know education why as far as you
know what it takes for them to be
pleasing to allah they would always do
the right thing and if they fear doing
anything that's going to displease allah
subhanho wa taala
they would always seek more knowledge
and wisdom and understanding it's going
to help them to be able to raise
themself and their family and then once
their self and their family is raised up
then they help to deal with the
community as well it's like you know we
flew in yesterday and home duty luck you
know when we got on the plane the first
thing that the people said on the plane
is in the event that the cabin loses
pressure then the oxygen will come down
when oxygen comes down said even if
you're responsible for children or
somebody else they put the oxygen on
yourself first because what happens if
you lose oxygen you don't have enough
oxygen you become disorientated and then
you can't help yourself or the other
person so it says put it on yourself
first and likewise with us we have to
educate ourselves on what is necessary
for us in this life you know in this
family in this community you know we
have to deal with it by itself first you
know with the help of allah subhanaw
taala
and then give it to our family or you
who believe save yourself and your
family from the torment of the fire you
know so it's our responsibility to
educate ourselves to get the education
if we don't know how to get the
education then go somewhere and find
somebody that has the ability to
articulate the information that is going
to help you to be a better servant of
allah subhanaw taala
therefore living the life that Allah
supports Allah created you to live you
know and that's our major objective and
helping families we've saved over a
thousand you know families from divorce
you know even some that had already
divorced you know they've already come
back you know some of them have come
back
and got remarried again because they
realized that they didn't have the right
tools or education in order to be a
beneficial person in the relationship of
marriage and then whenever you have the
marriages that are strong and tight you
know and they have the love of allah
subhanaw taala and they fear allah
subhana wa ta'ala and they have a hope
that Allah will facilitate their life
then hamdulillah then you have a
wonderful strong Ummah that's going to
be pleasing to our law so far north
Allah
therefore warranting the blessings that
Allah is capable of giving them so this
is now what you do now this is your
passion this is what you are fully
involved in is helping helping the
rebels counseling help marriage colleges
helping marriages helping Muslims with
Muslims arbitration helping those
individuals who have teenagers that they
don't understand what they need to do in
order to keep them around Islam people
make a lot of mistakes because they
don't have the right understanding they
don't know how to facilitate the growth
in their own families what you know what
is so tell us with your experience what
is one of the number one number two
three reasons that the families are
broken up is it that husband and wife
are not spending enough time together is
it that there's no order it's chaos
because what reasons it's bigger than
that because if people don't really
understand what their role is as as a
Muslim mate we got rules
everybody has rules you know and
everybody has rights inside of those
roles so the husband has certain rights
and certain responsibilities the wife
has certain rights and certain
responsibilities the children themselves
have certain rights and responsibilities
and the parents themselves have rights
and responsibilities and moreover allah
subhanho wa taala has rights over all of
us that we fulfill our obligation inside
of the institution that's created by him
a divine institution that's created by
him and overseen by him so we have to
find out you know what is our
responsibility and the institution of
marriage and family you know exactly
what am I supposed to do
we get together and we get married and
we say okay I'm gonna bring home the
money and you're gonna cook rice and
you're gonna do this you're gonna do
that you know what I mean but they don't
really understand what a loss of
Philomath LRC's as our responsibility
what is what is your wife's right and
are you fulfilling those what are your
husband the husband's rights and the she
fulfilling those and what is the rights
of allah subhanho wa taala this is all
part of marriage in Islam you know it's
not just us coming together having a
good one Lima you know what I mean and
everybody chicken and kill to you know
kill a sheep a lot of sheep you know
what I mean and everybody comes in and
talks and laughs and they go on about
our business no it's a responsibility
you know to a loss of her without our
first and foremost and if we don't do
that then we're gonna be standing
waiting to try to cross this around at
some point and Allah subhanAllah Ellen's
gonna hold us there because of we did
not fulfill obligation the way that he
had injected it in to the institution of
marriage when take a break and was right
back with more here with meiotic on the
Deen show no problem you can take my
daughter to dinner you and my daughter
and me it's naturally just and heated us
to have a good time we should have a
good time wise though Islam is the
fastest growing religion in the world
and most of the converts are women not
men they see that the rules of Islam
instead of constraining name the rule
set them free
back here on the D
imam tarik you know time is short yes
and these shows are really short and we
just want to kind of give people
motivation to continue to research to
continue to get convinced that this is
the way of life that paradise is true
there's something beyond this life
Hellfire is a reality
they have judgment all of this what
you've done in this life you'll be
accountable for and the Muslim family
you know if you've got good families you
have a good society see give us some
tangible things that you know those who
are married who are going to be raising
the future nation tomorrow you know that
they can do so they can produce good
children who are doing good and
community so we they could be successful
in this life in the next well first of
all we we encourage everyone to seek
more understanding regarding the
institution of marriage you know we pray
five times a day and we're obligated to
pray five times a day but prayer is not
considered half of your Deen how about
once a week during the jomon just or
Ramadan thank God that I'm busy more
important okay laws more important so we
pray five times a day five but it's not
considered half of the Deen we give
zakat aware obligated to give zakat but
it's not considered half of the Deen we
go to Hajj one time you know in our
lifetime if we can if we're able but
it's not considered half of the Deen but
marriage itself is considered half of
your religion and we have to understand
that it's one of the biggest
institutions of allah subhanho wa taala
so there's more to it than just a man
and a woman getting together you like
when she looks you like the way that he
looks and so far we get together we have
two three children you know and so forth
like that we run a business we have a
job it's bigger than that it's trying to
please allah subhanaw taala and whenever
we sit down with individuals when doing
counseling incidentally we have one
counseling center in Atlanta Georgia
over in Jonesboro and we also just
opened up a new Center in Houston Texas
area hamdulillah you know but we always
tell people in the very beginning we
asked them number one do you have a love
for allah subhana wa ta'ala and pretty
much every Muslim is not going to say
that they don't you know then we asked
them do you fear doing anything that's
going to be displeasing to our loss of
100 dollar and pretty much every Muslim
says the
yeah lots of home Donna and do you have
a hope that allah subhanho wa taala will
facilitate your life there will be
present in your life and help you be
successful in this life based on what a
lot of deems is success and they say yes
then hum did a lot and you're obligated
to live in a certain way you're
obligated to fulfill your obligation to
allah subhanaw taala
by being good to your wife by being good
to your husband by being good to your
children and educating them by being
good and and making sure that your
parents you know are safe in their and
their appreciate it appreciate it and
making sure that you have an
understanding of Islam and what allah
subhanho wa taala has given you as a
responsibility to be able to live in
this life and be able to earn gentlemen
a lot of us are falling short because of
the not because of the intentions
because there's a lot of people have
good intentions but there are people in
Hellfire to have good intentions so we
have to make sure that we understand and
educate ourselves on what our
responsibility is even in the
institution because this is one of the
quickest ways that you could get the
general is in your marriage and
fulfilling all of the rights of your
wife of your husband of your children of
the parents and of allah subhanho wa
taala
and also one of the quickest ways for
you to get to hellfire based on you not
fulfilling your obligation to those
individuals in your family where the
husband or wife or children or parents
you know and most of surely allah
subhanho wa taala because of the fact
allah is the one who created the divine
institution of marriage and we obligated
to go in accordance with what Allah
support Allah created Salah I hope that
you know what you you do this now full
time yes and if people now need some
counseling correct how can I get a hold
of you they get a hold to us at the
office in Atlanta Georgia we have opened
up a brand new office hamdulillah
everything is private and confidential
and they can call to eight one five two
nine six two seven two to get any kind
of information regarding is Islamic
counseling also they can go to our
website Islamic accounts
org they can find the information all of
the telephone numbers are there I'm
gonna live there and be able to read and
find out about what we do and how we do
it and how long we've been in in
business to helping the Muslim families
keep keeping the families together
keeping the families together there's
nothing there's nothing better there's a
Hadees or rasoolullah so it's alive you
know they said he asked some of his
companions he said shall I tell you what
is better than salat and fasting and
they said ya rasool allah what could be
better than salat and fasting he said
bringing people together yeah
arbitration helping them solve their
issues
what better issues can you fight against
Shaitaan with by bringing families
together and holding them solid there
for Allah so Allah will bless the Ummah
because it's blessing the families and
the individuals thank you so much for
being with us in law all right we'll see
you soon we appreciate you for having me
here
it's Allah and I may Allah reward you
for the work that you're doing this is
going all over the place thank you so
much Tom did Allah try the coffee
now another episode of the Deen show
thank you for tuning in every week we're
here with a new exciting show we got to
get it right this is the test of life
and God Almighty's given us the ability
the faculties to realize hey you know
what I'm not going to worship the
creation I'm gonna worship the Creator
I'm gonna humbly submit to all the
commands the wonderful things that the
crater's told me to do and he's got a
wonderful reward from me something that
you cannot imagine something that's far
better than anything that you can have
in this life paradise and I'm gonna work
hard to do good to be good and to avoid
the Hellfire god is the most-loving the
most merciful and he has sent guidance
throughout all the messengers the last
fundamental problem o Muhammad he has
brought what we need to keep our
families together to make our lives more
fruitful to have that peace that's the
verbatim order to gather the Quran which
you can get for free 1 800 662 Islam
give us a call give us a call to get the
verbatim Word of God
so you can understand it you can live by
it so you could truly be successful in
this life and the next and don't forget
to pick up the new dunya today know so
at the Deen show com we'll see you next
time until then peace be with